since you've found them easier let's do
question two first when writing these in
scientific notation
okay now we're trying to make sure these
numbers are we're looking for a few
different things so firstly we're
looking for a product of two numbers so
something times something secondly we're
looking for that first number which in
this case is five point four zero four
we're looking for that first number to
be between 1 to 10 okay and lastly we
want this number here to be 10 the curve
something and so far all those tickets
let's read through this one time five
million four hundred four thousand
because I start off by saying five
billion if all I had there was five
billion no other numbers how many zeros
just five billion times six so Tim to
the seats
perfect then you take the five that's
going to be your your one big digit in
point four zero four big thumbs up if
you've got that some people ask me how
many significant figures do we put on to
this question you put however many
significant figures
there are into the first place I don't
know anything about this number so how
many significant figures can I assume
that there are only four all right one
two three four
these may be significant but there's no
reason for me to say that they are
sometimes dance is perfect okay so that
looks good what do we think of that this
one who agrees with this on top yeah
okay thank you here's now so by the way
you've got a couple of choices here
especially with negative indices they're
easier to markup choice number one get
out a calculator remember we have this
button right we've got that you I mean
you can do this you can type it manually
if a B you got a button that does that
in one kit for you Cody okay clear now
type in 3.04 where's the button again
it's sort of mixed the decimal place I
think yeah bottom middle okay and then
put in negative three does it hate you
this number yes I had audiences
okay so that back cool okay so it's
hitting it back to you certificate issue
that's it okay so you've got some
settings of you calculate okay so thumbs
up there there is one other way we could
check rather than like appealing to
technology what this means is right
welcome back here Jenny what this means
is you're multiplied by ten six times
yeah so what this second one beat is
because it's a negative
you're not multiplying by ten you're
dividing by ten right dividing by ten
how many times that's a negative three
okay so every time you divide by 10 the
decimal place it shifts over one time
okay in fact so it shifts to the left
so if you divide once you're gonna get
0.304 yeah if I go again you're gonna
get zero point zero three zero four do
it a third time and this is the number
you get it's a lots of ways you can
check um last one yeah okay
it was a bit of mom right cuz you don't
have to do anything with it but if you
want in scientific notation you have to
include this guy um why what well
firstly you definitely should assign to
notation is we want this times ten to
the whatever it's a zero because how
many zeros after are there after the
five zero they're gonna series after
okay let's have a look at the Rabi so
two significant figures the most
important numbers sorry the most
important digits in this number three
the one so when you say five significant
figures what are the most important the
five most important numbers digit see
there's no but one two three four five
there they are
so you look at this guy and you say if
I'm to round to you are the rest of the
numbers to levy to round up or stay
where I am and you say because 20 is is
closer to lo okay so that's fine that's
fine also
fine ok so you seem to be good figures
I'm gonna ask the question together
which other three most important or the
three biggest numbers that you see here
in this we all these guys here are not
significant right just like just like
these guys
I don't significant right so therefore
you start there
here's the first one second one is that
one so then you look at the rest of them
up and you say does the rest of the
number tell me to go up or stay where I
am
and the answer is that's pretty full you
stay where you are okay
so happy times Oh take just see